Gina from Toluca Lake
has a question.
Aha.
Forrest, I've often wondered,
what would it be like
to kill a person?
Whoa.
"Whoa" is exactly right.
[sighs]
I want to choose my words
very carefully here.
Gina, I will do many things,
but to take a life
is wrong beyond all reason.
As a man who reviews life,
I simply have too much
respect for it to end one.
And so,
for the first time
in Review history,
I hereby enact
the power of ...the host veto.
[dramatic music]
Holy [bleep].
♪ ♪
[drumroll]
[sighs]
Thank you.
♪ ♪
Are you certain you wish
to veto this review?
Yes, I am.
Are you certain you wish
to veto this review?
Yes, I am.
Are you certain you wish
to veto this review?
Yes, I am.
You may veto
this review.
Thank you, Grant.
A.J., shield your eyes.
[drumroll]
[glass shatters]
Oh.
With solemn regard,
the first host veto
of the season
is hereby dutifully cast
by me, Forrest MacNeil,
being of sound mind.
Killing A Person:
vetoed.
[dramatic musical flourish]
Please destroy this...
and these.
[sighs]
That was exciting!